foreign
[Music]
let's take a moment and reflect this
morning April's National Stress
Awareness Month the National Institute
of Mental Health is reporting that
nearly 60 million adults live with
mental illness Lauren negretti joining
us live from UNLV this morning with the
stress that it takes on our bodies and
our minds and it's so important to find
some tools and you've got free tips
Lauren so take it away
that's right Heather good morning yes
National Stress Awareness Month
definitely an important topic to discuss
here but as you're heading out the door
this morning reflect on your thoughts
change those negative thinking to
positive thinking I'm here with Dr
manage Sharma with UNLV to discuss more
okay tips as you're headed out the door
this morning so one of the tips that I
would like to give in dealing with the
stressors so that we do not get distress
is to convert our negative self-talk
into positive self-talk the second one I
would like to give is to convert our
irrational thinking like for example we
may think that everybody should love us
that is not possible so we should
replace it with rational thinking like
moderate evaluation moderation and
everything so those kind of things are
very helpful and those are called as
problem focused coping and then the
other part is the emotion focused coping
in which we can do relaxation meditation
and the things like focusing on home
meditation or syllable meditation is
very helpful and I have written a book
called introspective meditations for
complete contentment available from
Amazon that gives all these tips very
easily in layman's terminology so if you
have time you can review that book
definitely and so really quick too uh
the OM helps you Center get out of that
fight or flight that's why we hear that
uh how to meditate 25 30 minutes you
were saying yeah it starts with 25 to 30
minutes to establish practice and then
meditation can become a part of your
life so you can start practicing it as a
way of life you know with each
inhalation you can focus on say for
example om and with each exhalation you
can focus on the tasks that you are
performing
perfect thank you so much doctor yes and
again you know some other practical tips
to keep at home there some breathing
exercises in this the national Stress
Awareness Month
that's when you'll be posting all those
online too so appreciative Lauren thank
you Sherry
um yes the omen the breathing exercises
seem a lot more easy it'll seem a lot
easier than the exercising to get rid of
stress